the US has recorded its highest one-day
death toll from the coronavirus more
than 500 people reported dead from the
virus in just the last 24 hours and that
brings the total nationwide to more than
3,100 people here in New York the
epicenter the Navy medical ship the
comfort is now docked and ready to take
patients not suffering from the corona
virus and therefore helping desperately
overrun hospitals here even Central Park
now has medical tents and mul LNG is
their mola good morning this is the
first time since the civil war that
there have been medical tents there in
Central Park
you got a tour what can you tell us well
Tori that tour was impressive and
sobering both at the same time this
field hospital is in part funded by and
operated by Samaritan's Purse they are a
charity group that does just this they
provide medical relief in crisis
situations these tents that you're
seeing here they've been all over the
world
Haiti after the earthquake there West
Africa during the Ebola outbreak and now
of course they are here in iconic
Central Park just a stark reminder of
the crisis facing this city and the
nation we're getting a first-hand look
inside these newly built field hospitals
now set up in Central Park specifically
for coronavirus patients these 14 tents
hold 68 beds we are gonna take overflow
patients if we can call them at from
some of the other hospitals our goal
will be to get them off of the
ventilator and move them on out of the
hospital
New York is also taking extraordinary
measures to deal with non coronavirus
patients the navy hospital ship comfort
has now docked at a pier in manhattan
equipped with a thousand beds with 2,500
more beds at the Javits Convention
Center the site of the US Open tennis
tournament is also going to be used for
350 temporary hospital beds we've lost
over 1,000 New Yorkers to me we're
beyond staggering already we've reached
staggering
most of New York City's deaths have
occurred in the past few days
we are bracing ourselves for something
we've never seen before in any of our
lives among the dead at least three New
York City health care workers the
Department of Corrections says 167
inmates and 114 staff members have now
tested positive in nearby New Jersey
eight residents of the Lakeland nursing
home have died others are now infected
it's a constant ache sue O'Brien is a
New York physical therapist with two
young girls she has not been able to
visit her husband Ted who has been
isolated and on a ventilator since he
was hospitalized less than two weeks ago
so I'm living moment-to-moment wondering
if I'm gonna get a phone call that they
can't save them
well this operations gonna be staffed by
about 60 to 70 doctors and nurses and
they will begin taking patients as early
as today
meanwhile across the country in Southern
California another 1000 bed u.s. naval
ship Hospital the Mercy is now taking
its first patients to free up space in
LA area hospitals that have seen around
2,500 coronavirus cases Anthony mola
legi in Central Park thanks mola